I've got this friend who drives a car
the only way to describe it is it's just
a piece of crap it's just the worst car
on the planet I mean I don't know and
here's the problem is the guy actually
has money like a lot of money but he's
just become a freak about this car he
like he'll spend money on other stuff he
takes his family on vacation and they've
got a nice house but he's like it's like
this car is some kind of a reverse
status symbol for this guy and you know
and you know Lord willing most people
more people would be like that rather
than driving around in cars you can't
afford with car payments to impress
people to stop like you'll never meet a
lot of you spend a lot of money to
impress people you will never meet with
your car and I've got some nice cars I
like cars I'm a car boy there's no
question about that but man when we were
broke we were driving well start with I
was driving a Jaguar and then I went
broke and I sold it the day before they
took it so that they didn't take it to
avoid the repossession the proper thing
to do to try to pay my bills of course I
didn't pay the whole bill I had to sign
a note for the difference and as part of
the bankruptcy it was a disaster
and so we're down to one car so a friend
of mine loaned me a car like my buddy
has he loaned me a true story of 1978
Cadillac with 478 thousand miles on it
the predominant color on this puppy was
bondo it had a vinyl roof and when you
drove it the vinyl roof was broken loose
so it filled up with air like a
parachute on top so I'm driving bondo
buggy with a parachute on top I drove
that car for 10 years one three-month
period but I saved some money buddy
because I wanted out of that car I want
to take my friend his blessing back but
it rolled it started most the time it
started most the time it rolled and it
got me there it was really real
embarrassing humiliating is a better
word to drive that car to our church
because that the church were going to
people didn't have cars like they had
nice cars a lot of them are in debt and
had car payments I knew that but I'm
still sitting there driving bondo buggy
with a parachute on top up to the church
I park it in the top settles like you
know he drops down that seems like 20
minutes ago it was almost 30 years ago I
drove like no one else so that later I
could drive like no one else so now I've
got nice cars again of course this time
there are a very small percentage of our
net worth a very small percentage of our
net worth and of course I paid cash for
them and they just in other words
they're small enough percentage of a
world they don't matter all my buddies
got money and we're he to buy at least
one decent car it would be a small
percent a very small percentage of his
world he's probably worth 20 million
dollars I don't know but something like
that and he's driving this $200 car and
it's ticking me off because I'm like
dude you are not modeling success here
you know this is not anything to be
proud of you drive a 200 dollar car so
that you never have to drive a 200 ollar
car again that's the only reason you
drive a 200 dollar car not because it's
a badge of honor it's not something to
be proud of son and I can't get through
to him so I don't know what I'm going to
do with it but he's the reverse of most
American most Americans the average car
payment in America is 386 dollars over
84 months right now driving a car you
can't afford not even close to being
able to afford it and then scratching
your head wondering why your kids
college fund didn't fund well you're
driving it you're driving the college
fund that's why I mean I get why my
friend has become such a freak about his
car I get why he's thinking that way
because so many other people most other
people are the opposite end of the
spectrum I mean he's a little overboard
and a little bit freaky about this old
beat-up car but most you are just stupid
I mean just most of America is just
straight up cars stupid you fleece your
car acting like that you when you rented
your car you did a good deal give me a
break and the stupid thing loses 60 to
70 percent of its value when you buy a
new one in the first four years that you
drive it so you turn thirty thousand
dollars into eleven thousand dollars and
scratch your head and wonder why you
can't get ahead financially what if all
your investments what of all your IRAs
you put money in a mutual fund every
time you did it you turn thirty thousand
into eleven well everyone knows that's a
formula for not getting rich hello this
is not hard to think about people it's
the largest thing we buy that goes down
in value that's why my friends become a
freak about it he's like I don't put
money and something goes down in value
I'm like yeah but you're embarrassing me
and everybody else that knows you buy a
car son even if you only spend ten grand
I mean it's what one one-one hundredth
of a percent of his net worth or
something but the rest of your drop you
know you're making thirty thousand
dollars a year you driving seventeen
thousand dollar car well is that that's
just nuts
it's just nuts you got a household
income of 60,000 bucks and mama gets a
$32,000 SUV somebody ought to smack you
that's just nuts you do not have the
financial margin to lose thirty thousand
bucks to lose ten thousand bucks to lose
twelve thousand bucks if you've got
enough money that you can throw twelve
thousand dollars off the edge of a
bridge and it not damage you then you
can afford to drive a car that expensive
but this idea that you can just I can't
afford it what most people mean when
they say that is they think they can pay
the payment if they keep their job let
me help you with a new definition if I
can afford it I wrote a check and paid
for it that's the definition of I can
afford it if you can't pay for it in
cash in total on the spot cash on the
Barrelhead you can't afford it whatever
it is your car your clothes your
groceries some of your charging
groceries huh talk about financing a
depreciating
acet Wow we've lost our minds in this
culture guys we really have and all of
it is because people have been sold
stuff and sold stuff and sold stuff and
they've got this entitlement thing and
they say you know I mean 42 year old men
who say stuff like I deserve a nice
truck because I work hard you don't
deserve anything you little child
because you work hard we think that
makes you pregnant nobody else is doing
nobody else is out here not working hard
well some of them are but me everybody
works hard deserves to go deeply in debt
by truck that can't afford is that what
you're saying that's your philosophy of
life
how stupid and backward is this so
here's an idea pay cash for your cars
and don't let your cars and boats be
more than half your take-home pay and
then that's an indication that you're
not got too much invested in things that
are going down in value
I'm not against cars I'm not against car
dealers I'm against people doing stupid
stuff with cars that cause them to be
broke and that includes car payments and
leasing fleecing your stupid car there
we go this is the Dave Ramsey show